but let's start first of all by a
statement which I'm putting forward
there of course to generate the
discussion it provokes some some
insights peaceful means to focus on
change from within rather than extant
driven reconstruction security and
economic paradigms key questions are how
do we ensure sustainability what is
sustainable peace building what does it
mean its sustainability in terms of
development such as defined by the World
Bank the IMF the UN how do we ensure
agency from below how do we ensure that
the peace actors on the ground are
actually modeling as you said modeling
their own agency modeling their own
ownership how do we actually get to
ownership what is local ownership who
decides what local ownership actually
means
who does that we the UN it's a community
or people on the ground
how does piece putting address the roots
of war and inequality how does it do
that something we have not seen in many
recent cases that in Afghanistan that in
Somalia well in Kosovo we'll discuss
that how do we allow for complexity to
inform contextualized approaches how do
we allow for interconnectivity to
actually generate hearings convergence
complementarity and actually agency from
below because the ideal that we have is
that those who are affected by the
conflict actually take the opportunity
Caeser between to build up their own
agency their own identity rather than us
coming in
dictating what reconstruction actually
means what a security actually mean like
I said I come from a peacemaking world
peacemaking has not done much of good
works in the last year's mediation is
not brought about lots of change it's as
mitigated conflict but we haven't
actually exchanged actors we haven't
exchanged structures we haven't actually
dealt with Catholic transformation at
all the same pundits are in the same
structures with the same powers and we
have used elections as the conduits to
put the same people into power with the
same agendas so we have actually changed
anything we want to do convict
transformation we want to do something
that is close to lyrics ideal but we
haven't done that actually UN policies
are not geared to this kind of work
you're in policy argues towards
peacekeeping that peace building can
come into place but we're not done peace
building it so you will see lots of new
research coming out articles publishers
publishers publications also through
professor Coleman's a research looking
at how can we now ensure that we talk
about peace building and what does it
actually mean when you look in from a
complexity perspective so peace means to
focus on change from within we would say
of course change from within you know
the people that are affected are the
PhDs of their own conflicts they know
best how to do that but at the same time
we argue in terms of development if you
don't set up your structures in your
banking system then you don't get money
how do then they change from within they
don't then it does no change happening
there's no individual change happening
it's a very amorphous field depending on
where you come from which discipline
it's going to have its own texture
important for us because we're living in
a international environment driven by
international laws is to look at
policies international policies that
actually dictate the way forward when it
comes to peace building and this one has
been started by Boutros boutros-ghali
and his his agenda for peace where he
says peace building is the action to
identify and support structures which
will tend to strengthen and solidify
peace in order to avoid relapse into
conflict I think everybody agrees on the
last one
we don't want actually societies that
come out of
or or violent environments to lapse back
into violence based on this definition
there has been lots of discussions and
talks about this idea of what we call
liberal peace building liberal because
it tends to focus on developments
development through financial aid
institution building state building and
state building means you know all the
structures around you that you need to
have a state functioning
so imagine South Sudan South Sudan has
its independence on July 9 2011 most of
the people in the ministries and the
government are from the bush unlike
Somalia where most of the people come
from no there's a 21 year old guy he
leads the ministry for infrastructure
and whatnot he has a PhD from Bradford
University so most of those people in
Somalia are exiles coming back into
Somalia and having little departments
well you know if you think about it if
you go to Mogadishu I mean there's not
much there anyway and if you're lucky
enough to have a proper department then
you have a little little house it has a
door and some windows and that's your
Ministry of infrastructure for example
but he's 29 year old he has done studies
he knows how to converse he knows how to
talk he knows how to charm the
international community South Sudan very
different 29 29 is a PhD 21 PhD but
young never this but say in South Sudan
most of them come out of the bush into
what the entire community says you have
to have for example a Ministry of
Finance
now if you know the context of South
Sudan and the different tribes and the
different affiliations they had you ask
yourself well how about finance many
people will say ask to be bad so we have
to deploy more troops more drones and
all that stuff no look at some of the
most violent pockets always have little
areas and her havens of peace peaceful
actors on the ground there - lots of
tremendous work why not identify those
actors and try to support them somehow
we can discuss how that functions but
try to support these peace actors on the
ground let's try to to find out about
those actors you might say well in
Rwanda for the genocide 94 we had at
least 120 NGOs on the ground that were
actually Peace NGOs they were trying to
do some work but there was a support
from the UN the UN said we don't have
the mandate to support these NGOs and
they lacked everything the lacked
transportation means they lacked
helicopters they lacked medical means
why not support those mind you wonder
was two years after he this and
definition came out why didn't we deploy
why didn't we go there okay so just many
questions there's no response as I have
right now we can discuss you will find a
lot of other models that criticize the
liberal peace model can we tearing
critiques and these are just a list that
you can research for yourself and find
and I can give you of course references
for all these critiques if I then take a
look at it my question as always is ok I
can see the criticism I understand why
for example is that good to jump right
away into State Building but the same
time what are the options are your
choices are you gonna stand there and
just watch people kill themselves
decimate themselves how many times
remember when the war in Bosnia broke
out anybody says no never again I
remember when I was there before I
signed up for for the Armed Forces basta
for me was actually the reason why we to
the armed force in the first place
because right before Bosnia there was a
big
big big big big argument for the golf
the goal for people in the streets when
the one boss near broke out nobody went
to the streets I'm of ours we were five
people in the streets demonstrating
against the war in Bosnia wanting
intervention we went to university you
know and coming from the school and
having little candles was cold like this
outside where is it little you know
Night Watch it isn't thinking that we
would actually do change anything no but
here before or two years before 1994 the
goal for masses of people and for boss
or nothing happened okay so some people
say no no we we cannot have this happen
again
Rondon 94 happened again there was a
genocide and look at other places I mean
it's always happening this tree
happening is happening all the time so
at the same time you have to say we need
an intervention but how do we intervene
what's the quality quality of this kind
of intervention how do we qualify our
intervention how do we not fall into a
culture of intervention so my question
is are we have to we have to go we have
to intervene we can look like things
happen but I'm not a proponent of r2p
neither because who's gonna pay for the
humanitarian costs in Libya or Somalia
who's paying for that so people are very
cautious to intervene in Syria who's
going to take the responsibility for
intervention Syria Libya might say was a
bit easier different balance of power of
course you might say that but look Mali
is a direct outcome of Libya all the
weapons used by insurgents in Mali are
weapons used in Libya I work on a case
for the World Bank where communities
fight one another and fight a big
company and I can trace the weapons back
that they use to the weapon Arsenal's in
Libya so there is again this
interconnectedness whatever we do
intervene here will cause an effect over
there there's a clear relationship
between the US troops withdrawing out of
Somalia in 92 93
the genocide 1000 T for the ages on the
ground that were perpetrating the
violence they were waiting for something
to happen because Bruni Ronda didn't
just happen
two years before the genocide it
happened 20 years already but there was
a strong force and when Clinton said no
no we're gonna get those troops back
after Black Hawk Down
you know the situation then it's all of
a sudden it generated another kind of
dynamical situation kind of wave of
violence it's where all of a sudden also
you lots of Richards coming back with
the whole complexity theory what
happened there what are these bubbles of
energy and systems that contracted
another intervention we have in Haiti
has actually a reference to intervention
in Papua New Guinea you know all that
stuff in terms of peacebuilding for
example the challenge of rebuilding
war-torn societies is to nurture and
create the political economic and social
space within which indigenous actors can
identify develop and employ the
resources necessary to build a peaceful
just and prosperous society this kind of
definition of current peace building
evolution has found its policy making
example in the New Deal or the MDGs and
the way that the New Deal or the MDGs
for certain emerging countries are being
prioritized so for example she will
online you will see the New Deal for the
DRC will tell you you know by that time
the country should have built up a
medical health system and in order to
get there these steps have to be taken
and these things have to be done so it
is about identifying what other
priorities when we come to peace pooling
and we come to foreign assistance from
outside what do we prioritize first in
those contexts do we say we rebuild in
tarnation do we say rule of law dictated
by the department leg Affairs in the UN
or the World Bank or do we say rule of
law based on what indigenous actors have
defined as their rule of law the problem
is and that's why I talk to you about
gaps and capacities
how do we nurture and create the space
because peace building is all about the
local entity the local system being able
to absorb all what's coming in terms of
change and to produce something that
resists the shocks and the crisis
without other intervention although I'm
a peacemaker I have to have a peace
building head on and that's where
interconnectors come in as a peacemaker
actually a manager of expectations I
manage not just my own mediation support
team but also manage the International
contact group the World Bank the UN
local population political parties
imagine all these people if I do it
right then they'd be able to actually
carry the process forward without my
intervention then they have to create
their own space they have to create
their own Haven how to resist to shocks
and crises for their own sake without my
intervention I have to lay out the
ground for that
so Mali for example it's a very very
good case in point so follow the
situation of Mali because that's going
to be a new way after Kosovo and East
Timor on how the UN looked at peace
building they are trying to adopt this
kind of mindsets that you have to
integrate peacemaking peace building and
peacekeeping altogether you know that in
terms of reaching positive peace the
segmentation between peacemaking
peacekeeping appeasement was built on
Johan galtung ideas and then later I
came afterwards and we find what Galton
brought out of course the question today
is that do we still look at peacemaking
peacekeeping peace building as it was
back in the days or shouldn't just go to
go back and look at pre-war war and
post-war situations that's why all of a
sudden you have very very interesting
people coming in this professor Coleman
but also others who think about ok let's
look at P spinning in a nonlinear way so
non-linearity is now of course the the
word of it of the game
what does it mean and before going into
really the the complexity of the topic
and I also gave you lots of indications
here where you can do your own research
but complexity and this is approach the
piece pooling says that whenever
managing am a changing environment two
of the indispensable capabilities of a
complex system are one to store
information about the environment and
second to adapt to structures set up
tivity ie to be self organized complex
systems need to have the capacity to
recall or somehow embody their own
history to have the memory yet memory is
not located at a specific place but
rather distributed throughout the system
how do we instill a new memory how do we
nurture a different history how do we
come into a post-colonial environment
such as Mali South Africa has its own
colonialism and it's still a new memory
how do these identities come together
and generate a new history a new
identity barrier that's also a question
identity and social systems how do they
do that how do we allow that to happen
yes it is a top-down bottom-up approach
but there is more more in this there's
much more stories that come together to
build up a structure to build up a
context how do we do that how do we get
there so in complexity for example as
the so called determined complexity
school they say if you gather enough
data and enough computer power we can
generate enough mathematical alterations
so we can understand at some point the
big picture and they're pursuing that
there is an the critical complexity
theory they say no no we can't do that
influence and likelihood is something
you're not you cannot compute it's going
to happen anyway so they are rather
argue from a position of power and
influence and what are certain likely
behaviors likely motivations likely
attitudes and we have to adapt quickly
to those if you want
understand those but more importantly we
have to understand how are these
structures able to adapt how they store
the information so if I go to South
Sudan for example and I work with
different actors on the ground I'm
asking myself when I go back to South
Africa to New York what do they do was
what I told them what do they do with a
change have I actually created an
environment where knowledge sharing and
best practices actually managed not a
sharing is very important reflective
practice is how do we create that so
when someone comes to me and donor and
says you know what I'll give you two
million dollars to conduct 25 trainings
over a period of three years I said I'm
not gonna do 25 trainings I wanna do
maybe three trainings one training per
year and the rest will be mentoring
mentoring mentoring mentoring mentoring
that is a key what we're trying to do
for example with UNDP and so-called
local mediators or in centimeters in
Somalia that they start sharing their
own stories their own context their own
memories they become resilient
themselves if I'm not off the bus this
resilience research in river management
the Nile management or is amazing River
management research has proven that this
kind of storytelling is actually quite
key to generate resilience in a system
to generate their own memory to generate
an activity to structures they didn't
start organizing their own structures we
might have Nadia of a democracy web love
law and we have to allow the local media
to have their own ideas of rule of law
what does it mean I can't come with my
ideas because I'm the intervener but you
are the intervened upon the sub-dominant
what is going to be your discourse do I
accept your discourse what do I say no
no no the World Bank said by this time
you have to reach this it's one Africa
for example they don't talk about
peacekeeping the way that the UN talks
about peacekeeping right peacekeeping
for the UN is between two people two
parties two entities keep the peace
let the ceasefire mediation works its
way and then there will be elections and
then tada a new state right
that that's what they did in Kosovo and
his team or its the blueprint work for
free well that was the blueprint right
that's how it's supposed to function
yeah well it doesn't really function
like that in every place and so the
Africans have said well no no it's not
going to be called peacekeeping for us
it's gonna be called peace support
operations pre Support Operations is a
war situation it's peace enforcement
through the means of war
the Africans say our context is dictated
by different dynamics certainly the post
: dynamic and all these tensions and
trauma is building up to something very
violent we have to have a force that
comes in between separates the party so
an African mediator is always a very
strong mediator in a sense that he has a
very robust mandate and a very robust
force in the background Mali is a
perfect example the president of Burkina
Faso is not a mediator here's a very
strong force backed up by France the
u.s. is providing drones and
interoperability and it's the best he
can do time machine excellent that's the
best they can do that's that's the way
currently how mediation is functioning
is going to happen for the next ten
years at least but this problem is again
how we bring peace positive peace in the
narrative Afghanistan is not going to
happen in 15 50 years South Sudan is
gonna happen in 100 years in terms of
what we think universal social norms are
about before they're really having their
own memory their own history their own
identity it's gonna take time a lot of
time so time should not be our worry
time is not the problem
there's a great movie The Fifth Element
I only know about if I do piss off in
the beginning they these aliens land and
then they are supposed to save a key or
you know save a certain artifact and
then one guy says why we run out of time
then this alien says time is not the
essence time we stop the problem because
they have been building up their history
for longer generation then actually the
humans beings were there for in the
story and that's the same in sustainable
peace building it's not about time it's
not about if you see peace coming about
in South Sudan so gonna be about you
talk a bit about the individual at all
anyway but the organization the group
the community how do they do that how
they learn are they adapt how do they
build interconnectivity but only between
themselves but also to other systems
outside how did all these agents work
together how do they build up their own
identity how does it happen how does it
function what do we do as peace builders
to do that are you focusing on youth are
we focusing on women are we focusing on
reconciliation what do we do how do we
do that forms and practice of peace
being are dictated by external
determinants those are the UN the World
Bank the IMF the u.s. in large parts but
also the European Union those actors
dictate how peace playing is supposed to
function in certain emerging states
fragile states you name it there's a
certain decline in that narrative
because you have another narrative
coming up which is build up by the BRIC
States Brazil Russia China India in
South Africa they are looking at a
non-interventionist model of peace
bowling where they say no no we have to
focus on local ownership that's why you
have an African Union that says African
solutions to African problems and this
will come up more and more and you will
see it will actually put aside the
narrative coming from the World Bank the
u.s. IMF that let's say the liberal
peace building model currently again we
have a piece being practice that leads
to achievement of negative peace it is
focusing much more on peacekeeping and
on how peacekeeping through
means of Elections rebuilds a state but
peacekeeping is not peace it's not
instilling peace per se
it keeps the parties apart but doesn't
do anything for the daily rock type of
conduct transformation that you are
seeking what's the transformation about
and again if you do transformation you
have to start with individual that's
where it starts individual it means when
we could do training we train an
organization for example but it starts
with individuals first and that is a
very very difficult thing to do I'm not
sure who of you people are working in
training I know Beth isn't training but
if you start with individual to really
change organizations how do you do that
it's actually quite difficult so
sometimes you work with the proxies of
agents of change or champions do all
these people who determines what
champion is it'll be me the mentor who
determines that you are champion of a of
change how do you do that what we need
is to explore the potential of
indigenous peacemaking bring back
traditional means of peacemaking
but peace building on running your
peacemaking with a certain purpose
peacemaking bring back the peacemakers
they are the conduits to generators of
stories structures and context they will
lead to positive peace to building peace
in their societies but you have to first
of all try to endorse these traditional
means of a peacemaking local mediators
places such as West Africa that have
been in the influence of French
colonialism for a long time they have a
very rich practise of indigenous
peacemaking a very rich practice why
don't we use those practices Mexico
Colombia if you look at the ADR story
from ADR perspective and law you'll find
lots of research on how local
communities local courts are actually
making very nice work in Mexico and
Colombia and Guatemala why don't we use
the same kind of situation political
science
why do you have to use always the
rational actor perspective who is an odd
rational actor in of in a violent
environment you're a rational actor so
the emphasis is here on post conflict
transformation in convert transformation
you have also three ideas prescriptive
elicited and inductive approach
inductive is again the agency from
within don't teach the PhDs of their own
conflict what they have to do to resolve
the conflict your system like are you
like a therapist you know that's the
other part of mediation the therapist
you just help them your assist them to
see a different perspective mediation is
exactly working at this dangerous border
of trying to change perception and
perspective it's very difficult to do
it's very hard work to do and I have
seen in research and activities that
women are actually better to do that
than men
that's why laverna we have to look at
how do we actually build up a you female
lead mediators there are better of
restoring something they're better at
communicating a change of perspective
than their male counterparts and it has
of course to do with a bigger narrative
less masculine tease and femininities
something we can also discuss but it has
to come from within and with respect for
the other do no harm is one thing and
it's fine
of course intervention by whom for whom
for the sake of whom dictated back home
but respect for the other is actually
much more important than do no harm
because if I respect the other I want to
harm at all I will come in I would ask a
question
I won't dictate like I'm fighting with
my counterparts in South Africa all the
time when they come and say you know we
are gonna have 40 trainings a year I
said no no food trains a year we do for
trainings we've been together identify
the knowledge allow the learning
environment so I'm moving away Percy
from train to learning I'm trying to
start you to hate the word training I
don't know what trainee actually does it
doesn't change anything training we're
trying to scale up a certain person to
function according to certain
performance criteria but we don't change
anything you haven't asked the person
what do we need to change in you we
haven't
so how about moving from training away
moving away from capacity to knowledge
sharing and providing a learning
environment that means in terms of
training it is the participants who
designed their own training it's a very
new way to see things and it's not just
starting now they sound a couple of
years ago but it's about the
practitioners in the field of academia
education and of course practice to take
all these ideas and to say we have to
relook at how we do certain things we
have to go as NGOs back to the donors
and tell them our narrative has to be
different we do training we're gonna
look at something different because
donors will come and say well we give
text money we want to see results at the
other day results base management that's
fair but doesn't change anything in the
donors and we have to do better work at
being a better advocate for our target
audience that we know much better than
the donor do how do we do that that's
where it starts that's where peace
building 2.0 starts it starts with us
and how we reach out to the other with
respect to the other and how do we
engage in those things